I'm on my way to meet a man who has been
chosen to lead his people in an epic
struggle one that also requires
superhuman endurance he's asked me to
come to Devil's Tower in Wyoming
this is chief horrible-looking Lewis the
chosen one of the Nakota Lakota and
Dakota tribes
I'll call I really wish to AH washday
waffle Atlanta I brought him a gift of
tobacco for his sacred ceremony oh thank
you so chief tell me why did you want me
to meet you here at Devils Tower we call
it mud hole tip ella mató tequila ah
that's one of our powerpoints a prayer
of worship it's like a church this is
where White Buffalo Calf woman brought
their sacred pipe to our people so the
story is that nineteen generations ago
our people were camped here at the time
there was no more food because people
were abusing life from a distance they
saw a cloud and then from that cloud
there's a woman she brought that sacred
pipe
she said I'm bringing this sacred bundle
to you that you shall live in peace and
harmony
[Music]
the White Buffalo Calf woman tall sheets
are those people how to respect mother
earth and worship the Great Spirit with
the sacred pipe she gave them if they
still exist yes since stage at 12 years
old I've been on the keeper of the
sacred white bottle-cap
bundle or pipe they call me Chon oppa a
wanker
chalupa a wanker Mme
the White Buffalo Calf piped the so
sacred that chief Orville cannot let
anyone outside his tribes see it so your
grandmother was the keeper of the pipe
yep she said that you were to be next in
line yes my grandmother on her deathbed
she told my family we are the crossroads
earth changes climate changes and that
if the people don't straighten up then
he shall be the last bundle keeper
[Music]
[Music]
you